so here we're going to demonstrate how
the components as we demonstrate all
that as we just showed a little while
ago in the course to import our file
remember it is a text file and we got
our PC a results let's give mine that is
a tabbed eliminated file and here we see
our first two components and again the
first one accounts for 21.6%
point six place seven percent of
variability second one four nine point
two percent of variability you want to
select those first two components insert
a scatter plot and here it our scatter
plot and we just change that chart title
and I'm just gonna call it PCA results I
hope it click on one of these markers
here all of them will be highlighted and
we can change some very abilities of
those markers for example size here and
then we want to go and select our data
and I want to change the series and
names to TN and then we can select the
first component for TN which is gonna be
the x-axis
well I access to select
second component for TN and then we can
add another series for our er samples
x-axis first component for ER y-axis
second component for ER
NBC are er samples are coated with
orange and our TN samples with blue
increase the size here
those the same size
and then we can move it little chart to
a new sheet
as we see here